if you're in a situation where you
should do something and the excuses roll
in you only have five seconds before the
excuses win that's it Juanes or get a
mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Mel Robbins and the five-second
rule that will change your life mentor
me Mel
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
links are in the description below if
you didn't give what anybody else
thought what's the thing you would love
to be doing with your life you might
want to get honest with yourself like
instead of doing this be a billionaire
or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
in order to get to the next level in
your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now so the five
second role is a self coaching tool
that's all that it is okay and it's
something that I invented literally 20
feet from here in my bedroom although
that bedroom wasn't built back then it
was something that I invented to beat my
habit of hitting the snooze button hmm
and the way that it works is very simple
the moment that you need to do something
and you can feel yourself hesitating and
you can feel the excuses rolling in
count backwards to yourself 5 4 3 2 1
and something weird will happen the
moment you get to one you'll actually
move and I invented it by mistake I
invented it during I think the worst
moment of my life which was 2008 Chris
and I my husband of 22 years we were
about to lose everything
well his restaurant business was going
under I had just been fired from a job
my first job in the media business so I
was just wallowing and self-doubt
because I thought boy have I really
screwed up I had changed my career
taking a risk gone into the media
business it didn't work out I felt like
a total loser I felt like I made a big
mistake we had three children mortgage
to pay the entire house had been used to
leverage the business so it our life
savings so at the kid's college savings
I mean just on the
of losing it all Chris was sleeping on
the couch and I just couldn't get out of
bed and so I invented this thing the
five-second rule one night when I saw a
rocketship fly across a television
screen at the end of a commercial and it
gave me this idea and the idea was hmm I
wonder if I launched myself out of bed
so fast I wonder if I could move fast
enough that I could beat the self-doubt
and anxiety that I felt every single
morning when I would wake up and it was
really that dumb and that simple of an
idea and for whatever reason when the
alarm went off that next morning what
happened is what happens to all of us
all day long
inspiration strikes so the alarm goes
off and used the thus knew who used the
alarm clock as a metaphor for those
moments when you know you should do
something and the alarm goes off and
what's interesting is most of us don't
have a problem with what we need to do
it's how we make ourselves do the shit's
hard so the alarm went off and
immediately my mind woke up and my mind
started spinning as our minds do and I
started immediately thinking like most
of us do when the alarm goes off I don't
want to get up on I you know it's cold I
want to get faced a day I'm an employee
and then the body starts to kind of get
a little tense when anxiety comes in or
you start to feel overwhelmed about this
you got to deal with and I felt myself
reaching for the snooze alarm like I
always did but that morning I went 5 4 3
2 1 and by the time I hit one I was
standing up and I was kind of freaked
out because why would something so
simple work but I went on with my day
and I used it the next morning and the
next morning the next morning and then I
started to wonder god I see that it
works as a cheat for the alarm clock but
I wonder if it could work for other
things so I started to use it for every
moment in my life where I knew what to
do but I didn't feel like it 5 4 3 2 1
literally just decimates any excuse that
you have
and as I started to use it in my life -
five four three two one not be an
[ __ ] - Chris five four three two one
turn and walk away from the Bourbon and
not have a drink five four three two one
pick up the phone and network five four
three two one walk out the door and go
to the gym everything changed because my
decisions changed if you're in a
situation where you should do something
and the excuses roll in you only have
five seconds before the excuses win
that's it and it has to do with how your
brain is designed and so I started
seeing this five-second window
everywhere everywhere you walk into a
networking meeting and the five second
window is right there because you look
around and you see all these people you
should talk to and you feel yourself
freeze five four three two one and you
can start walking if you're trying to
sell something the five second window is
always there because you either have a
phone you need to pick up and make a
phone call or you have a person you need
to talk to but instead of doing it that
five second windows right there and the
excuses roll in and then you're not
doing it yep and so I almost like we
talked ourselves out of it right after
five seconds that why not to do it all
and then it's even more sophisticated
than that is which is what I discovered
and what's more sophisticated about it
is that you have two modes to your brain
you have the prefrontal cortex which is
the mode of your brain it's the front
part of your brain that does all your
strategic planning your decision-making
your not only your decision-making
that's wrong it does your intentional
decision making conscious decision
making it's what you're using when
you're acting with courage it's what
you're using when you are learning
anything new if you've ever taken a
standardized test when you walk out of a
standardized test what do you have you
have a freaking headache because you've
been using this part of your brain
that's the one part the other part is
the interior part of your brain which
automates everything it's where self
doubt is it's where habits are it's
where automated decision-making is it's
where every negative [ __ ] that we do
it's stuck right here so what the
five-second rule is actually doing on a
very sophisticated
is it's switching off this part and
awakening the part that gives you
control and so the problem with our
excuses if you want to get into the
brain science is that if you start to
think and you start to think I feel
tired or I don't want or I'm too
stressed out or now's not the right time
that becomes automatic and it gets
encoded right here so part of the
problem with our excuses is that when
you stop and think and hesitate you
trigger your brain to automatically talk
you out of it that's the problem it's
not the excuses it's that your brain has
done it over and over and now it takes
over so I invented the world's most
powerful cheat code for the brain one
night when I was drunk
sitting in my living room watching
television now I've got a special bonus
it from Mel on how to do it any way that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that is some of the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what difficult
decision are you sitting on right now
number two what will your life look like
once you come out on the other side of
that decision and number three count it
down 5 4 3 2 1 and go do it anyway is a
mindset trick that you can use when you
start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule so
you have said to yourself okay I'm gonna
talk to my boss today about that thing
that I've been avoiding talking to them
about or maybe you've said something
like I'm gonna go to the gym today or
tomorrow whatever and then the moment
comes where you've got to have that
conversation or the moment comes where
it's time to pack up your bag and leave
your desk and go to the gym and what
always happens you don't feel like it I
bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that yeah
I'm not gonna have a drink tonight and
then guess what happens when you get
home you don't feel like not drinking
you feel like having a drink and so
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that I really want to do I need to
do I should do but when the moment comes
I don't feel like it and so I pull out
this idea of you know what I'm just
gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside I said I would go
for a short run I don't feel like it
I'm gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock
in the morning I'm tired it's cold I
laid out my yoga clothes but now I don't
feel like it what do I do I do it anyway
when you start to say to yourself I'm
gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you you acknowledge them and you
basically say guess what I'm gonna do it
anyway if you want to learn how Mel
deals with stress and depression check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there it's
really easy to isolate yourself what I
want you to do is I want you to actually
make a more concerted effort to reengage